[Music]
Newell has five progression systems that
all work together every action that you
take in new world has a reward to it the
most basic form of player progression is
leveling your character every time you
level up you get points to put into your
attributes second one is weapon mastery
the way I use my weapon the better I get
with that weapon I can assign points to
give me weapon abilities the third one
is our trade skill progression whether
I'm a gatherer or an blacksmith the more
I do that thing the better at it I get
the fourth one is territory standard
just by playing in a territory you'll
gain territory standing which gives you
access to bonuses like increased
experience reduced fees and houses then
the fifth one is factions you join a
faction at some point in the game if you
want to experience the PvP side as you
do faction missions you gain faction
reputation that enables me to get better
gear and goods from the faction which is
very cool gear so there's a lot of
different ways you get to experience the
world of a term and these are just the
first ones that you'll get to taste
we really wanted to have a deep crafting
system in your world everything in the
game supports it in one way or another
as you craft in new world you become
stronger and stronger and crafting and
when it comes time to craft a sword
you're gonna start out just being happy
to get something slightly better than
the basic sword one of the things you
eventually can do is add perks to the
weapons and those different reagents
come from the different gathering skills
so expert gatherers will be a source of
these rare resources that craftsmen need
to craft these special perks on to their
items these bonuses can range from
increased damage reduced weight or even
imbuing the weapon with elemental power
there are several ingredients that you
can use that sort of push the direction
of like what perks you're gonna roll
later on perks are gonna be things like
the sword deals extra fire damage and
actually is emitting fire as you wield
it weapons can also have gem slots and
you can take gems that you find out in
the world and slot them into the weapon
to add even more additional effects
crafting weapons and armor gives you an
outlet to where if I'm not finding drops
but I do discover a recipe I can try to
craft items that really suit my play
style and are very unique between perks
gems and the crafting skill families you
have massive amounts of control over
your crafts depending on the time you
want to spend in it you can become the
best craftsman on the server
[Music]
our trade skill system features endless
progression as you create things you get
experience points that give you levels
you can level forever when you start to
pursue a crafting trade skill you'll
start as a total novice you'll begin by
crafting the most basic of things for an
armor it'll be boots for a weaponsmith
it'll be a basic iron longsword as you
improve you'll unlock more recipes and
the recipes will begin to have higher
quality outcomes in general the things
that your crafting are better than they
were before we have a lot of different
trade skills armor smithing weapons
smithing cooking and a whole bunch more
let's say you're a level 10 armor
Smither
you can make an iron breastplate which
is pretty cool if your level 40 armor
smithing you can maybe make a steel
breastplate maybe if you're a level
hundred you can make a star metal
breastplate which of course requires you
to have cooler and better ingredients
this is one of our many progression
systems inside of the world
[Music]
working on new world has been a crazy
experience
I want players to fall in love with the
art and the places that we've
established I'm really hoping to expand
the world to create new and interesting
spaces on the island that you haven't
seen with new dangers and new things to
discover
I hope people really enjoy the combat
system and I want people to experiment
with it treat your own specializations
your own playstyle
every type of player can find something
that they enjoy doing whether they want
to be a crafter or an explorer or a war
hero we think of the launch day for new
world is day one we plan to work with
and listen to the players and just keep
growing and growing the game there's so
much to do in the world but we want to
continue adding more and more we just
cannot wait to get everyone in the world
playing the game
you